we turn now to three-time Oscar nominee
that Sylvester Stallone for decades he
has been one of the most recognizable
movie stars in the world that face that
voice there's only one now Stallone is
starring in the new Paramount plus
series Tulsa King from the creators of
the hit show Yellowstone so you know
they know what they're doing and the
gloves are off you could say he plays a
Mafia Boss exiled to Oklahoma to build a
new Criminal Empire after getting out of
prison CBS Sunday Morning correspondent
Lee Cowan sat down with Mr Stallone the
other day ahead of the show's Premiere
to hear how he is still going so very
strong
I took an oath
and I honored it this is Sylvester
Stallone like you've never seen him
before it sounds like a cliche I know
but just ask him have you always wanted
to play it oh yeah I kept saying what is
score say is he blind I mean how much
more than I'll tell you I'm joking I'm
not and I'm not I am sort of not really
why don't you pull over there
to wait a little bit until I come out
this will compensate you for your time
Tulsa King the latest streaming series
from our parent company Paramount is all
about an ex-con who hopes to get back
into his New York crime family not
exactly the welcome I was expected but
instead he's told to Head West to build
up a new crime crew in the middle of the
Oklahoma Plains pretty worship I really
don't go to church
all right you said that fans of yours
are really going to see
who you are in this role as opposed to
some of the other ones yeah
you're going to say I'm A demented
sadist after everything I've been
through after everything I've lost after
everything I've done for this family
your family
there's nothing left for me
look I know I'm not your man look at the
mirror I'm going who stole my face
I was here a few years ago
and I get it but I'm very young at heart
I just want to do a dialogue check while
he's a creature of older Hollywood he's
certainly learning new things Tulsa King
is the very first TV series he's ever
done and he's taking it seriously you
could Speed Ahead a little bit please
sometimes rewriting entire scenes just
the night before it's the way he's
always made movies he says that's how he
brought Rocky to life
[Applause]
I was a miserable failure I was the only
guy who said he went to four years to
college to become an usher you know but
I did I said how am I going to learn
filmmaking then I would take an old
cheap tape recorder record the dialogue
of a bad film and say can I do better
than that and I would literally replace
dialogue it was almost like a a
crossword puzzle it's hurry as well but
it's worth repeating by his own account
he wrote Rocky when he was so poor he
couldn't pay the rent I live in a flop
house where you share a bathroom with 10
transients yeah and I could lock the
door I would close the door and open the
window from my bed and that's where he
wrote that's what I wrote
he's had a number one box office hit in
every one of the last six decades it
between a course there were the not so
memorable roles
[Music]
sometimes the phone stopped ringing and
he wondered if it was all over if you
ever have people that actually give you
a helping hand when you're down that
actually pick up your phone call when
you're not valuable to them anymore
you're not an asset
that's a French so here he is at 76 not
really Reinventing himself he says but
just trying to be comfortable in his own
skin as long as you got this like
inside of you
do not age gracefully don't be like Oh
I'm just gonna go out there and fish
with the kids no I'm gonna go Harpoon a
whale bare-handed doesn't strike me that
you're ever gonna give this life up
like you're going to be in front of a
camera somewhere doing something yeah
you know I I I thought I could I thought
I could
but
I'm sort of obsessed with it as Rocky
once said It ain't about how hard you
hit it's about how hard you can get hit
and keep moving forward and Sylvester
Stallone has always done that for CBS
mornings I'm Lee County in Hollywood
[Music]
that was a great I like it now don't you
want to see that I love his attitude
don't go fish with the kids Harpoon a
whale bare-handed I like that don't
don't age gracefully do not age Grace
don't do that I thought you had a 10 of
my boss and now yeah this is the first
time that he's ever played that but the
thing is he looks so good too yeah looks
so good he looks hungrier than ever for
success I like that digging this I know
you see that tattoo going through I
think he did that himself he just
yeah no doubt that was great I think so
too the first two episodes of Tulsa
Tulsa King it's called you think I'd get
this one Tulsa King stream this Sunday
on Paramount Plus